welcome back to new rock stars and with
the Last of Us hitting the scene in a
big way it proves that the zombie hype
is even harder to kill than the zombies
themselves everyone loves the book of
zombie apocalypse but what if I told you
that Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
was about to get a bite of that zombie
apocalypse action and what if I told you
that Janet Van Dyne was the future
mother of zombies in the MCU this is
real Theory the show where we [__] the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love a show made possible by the
support of nordvpn more on those
beautiful people in a little bit but my
name is MD and Gordon world with me
today is the zombie Scarlet Witch it is
Whitney van laningham what's going on
baby what's going on Mt we're freaking
twins today we're matching with the [__]
oh dude I freaking love these shirts so
much listening on the podcast and not
looking at our beautiful shirts we are
wearing a quantumania Kang shirts and we
didn't plan this we're just
about like an ad
we have telepathy that that's that's
just how we progressed as friends
um
but it is um the zombie Overlord himself
it is Tom Michaelson what's going on Tom
well I guess I thought Tommy would be
the Zombie Overlord but I'll take it
I'll be today
like you know what was that uh what's
that Zack Snyder uh Netflix zombie one
where they have uh cybernetic zombies
they're not dead the dead oh man look at
it no Army of the Dead
I have no idea I've actually never
watched a zombie TV show I've only ever
seen zombie movies I don't think I've
ever watched any single Zombie series
like not on purpose I just like I just
realized that right now oh well Glenda
you know well other than other than the
last of us there you go now you know you
got one under your belt if you're
watching Last of Us
y'all it's the tits and I'm obsessed
with it
well I'll just I'll just be the overlord
of all zombies of all all Lord we'll
take that empty thank you I'm zombie
Mommy because I'm Scarlett
you know what every zombie Overlord
needs a zombie Co Overlord so zombie
coverlord Tommy told in the house
oh it's great to be here with my three
best friends in the whole world and I
have nothing further to say because I am
so excited to share my theory coming up
after the break hey yes he's going to be
amazing right after these messages it's
always a very special episode when
Tommy's around
I got caught smoking that's why today's
especially
best behavior or else these things will
kill you
hey but you know what else will kill you
a zombie apocalypse and um I think we
lead us to our first topic here
um what I think that there's a
possibility that Janet Van Dyne made the
zombie virus that we saw in what if for
King the Conqueror for to to have him
make a zombie apocalypse as part of his
plans to take over the timeline
um and I because we if we see in the the
Ant-Man the Lost quantumania trailers
Janet keeps talking about how she's
ashamed of something she's like I I
haven't told you guys some stuff like I
have some Secrets I haven't told you
there seems to be something that she's
trying to hide from her family and I
think that and we know that you know
Janet Van Dyne is this Super Genius
microbiologist who just knows so much
about the quantum universe and like
the quantum viruses and all that stuff
so like I feel like it's a possibility
that she used to work for Kang
um in a science Division and maybe
developed this zombie virus by accident
and Tang wants to use that for his own
ends what do you guys think of this
weird possibility
let me just ask I I don't I don't I'm
not ready to make a judgment yet I need
to ask a question is this yes in a
what-if world are you proposing this
theory in Quantum Mania the movie coming
up we're gonna find that out where where
where is this information being
disclosed or like Marvel Zombies yeah
I'm saying about it
so I'm saying that in Quantum Mania that
it will be revealed that Janet Van Dyne
made a zombie virus hurricane or just
made the zombie virus in general and
then Kang is like I want that [__]
Marvel Zombies because everyone likes
the left of a zombie
if I if I may continue this exploratory
round of questioning are we gonna see
this zombie virus like on a shelf
labeled like Janet Van Dyne zombie juice
it's gonna it's gonna be in a beaker
that says uh Janet van zein
but no I feel like you know everyone
like loves zombies they feel like Marvel
Studios knows that like there is The
Walking Dead obviously there's The Last
of Us now and like they already
announced a Marvel Zombies project in
the works already so I feel like there
is a big possibility that we could see
the Avengers or maybe even the midnight
Suns battle a zombie army because let's
be real in an Avengers movie produced by
Disney The Avengers or a large group of
Heroes cannot kill real people like
you're never going to see The Avengers
slaughtering like real life human beings
to fight like you'll ever you see robots
like Age of Ultron you'll see aliens
like Avengers one and you'll see zombies
eventually and we need a zombie army in
the MCU eventually so yeah there's
people in half but not be yeah not have
like Bloods be whatever because they're
they're Undead so it's okay you can kill
them now exactly it and like our moon
night was our first little taste into
the zombie weird after uh life and I
really liked like I always think about
that weird scene with um that weird see
that scary scene with with Steven and
Laila other like that horror scene I was
like oh I was genuinely scared I want to
see more of that I want to be more more
scared because I'm the biggest force on
the planet or even like in Spider-Man
not far from home when Mysterio is
making the zombie Iron Man come out the
grave yes that was pretty dope too and
that was I feel like them dipping their
toe in this but I love this Theory
because you know that would that would
raise the stakes for what the movie's
about I think we've talked about this
before uh on Rogue Theory but you know
if ant-man's goal was to stop the the
Marvel zombie virus from escaping the
quantum realm and destroying the
universe that would be pretty dope like
imagine if it really if he really was
raising an undead army or trying to do
that it would also be another way to
bring back some actors like you know hey
Chris Evans you want to dress up as a
zombie and get sliced in half by our own
Shield that would be dope oh and I was
gonna say um let's not forget that um
you know uh Janet has like magical beam
powers or she could go so in the second
one she she put her hands around ghosts
and cured her somehow with her magic
light hands that was the power of prayer
she couldn't pray her dad
I really thought you said magic bean
hands
Bush's Baked Beans will heal you
it's like Papa she opens up a can of
beans and shoots beans oh my God exactly
confirmed confirmed for quantumania but
no I think that's really fun because it
would you're right she's a scientist
she's super smart she knows a lot about
um altering the human body like if I'm
working with Hank on the Pim formula and
and now she's got magic powers right
from the quantum realm there's no
telling what she could do so that's
really cool yeah man she's a smart
cookie smart magical cookie uh Bean
sorry magical Bean smart little smart
magical Beast
she genetically engineered the beans
that from Jack and the Beanstalk yeah
exactly that's what I was thinking
hands I was like does she make a giant
fall out of the sky like what are you
talking about didn't you see Emma the
Wasps when he goes on part with the
Beast
scene yeah it was a whole third act that
Scott climbed a beanstalk yeah yeah are
you even a real Marvel fan Whitney I
don't think
but like this is a this is a really
Rogue hypothetical that has sort of
nothing to do with this but like
remember those zombies from what if that
like um Ultron Infinity dumped on a
planet to fight um The Avengers yeah
like what like what if like one of the
possibilities of us seeing those zombies
specifically crossing over into the MCU
because we know that the incursions are
coming and like Secret Wars is coming so
like do you think that we'll ever see
like the window open up and like the
zombies pour out into the 616. oh yeah
yeah for sure especially since I'm sorry
oh sorry yeah go ahead no go ahead I've
already said something I was just
because especially since like we already
got that little introduction that little
taste of cartoons entering the zombies
the like live action reality of the
Marvel Universe in uh Multiverse of
Madness when he's like spinning around
and then they go into like your cartoon
world so I do think it's possible that
we could see like the little crossover
between like the what if zombies and the
Marvel zombies and then now new zombies
from Janet van dyne's Bean hands
[Music]
[Laughter]
I also just think it would be really
funny if Janet's like dark secret from
the quantum realm is just that she got
way too into her improv troop and became
really obnoxious about it and she just
doesn't want her family to like go back
down and
[Laughter]
listen guys I got really bored I needed
a hobby it was a weird phase of my life
I'm sorry like just don't look into it
I'm sorry I'm sorry improv in the
quantum realm is really cringy and I
apologize for what you might see when
you go down there it's like you were
different here I don't know and their
response would be it's it's cringy
everywhere uh
[Laughter]
no I made zombies I made zombies
everything I mean zombies
the zombies it's the name of my zombies
I'm not your mom I am a Spanish Matador
can't you tell by my space also can I
get another profession one more can I
get another one more profession anybody
this is why mantis and Drax hated actors
in the holiday specials it makes sense I
just don't like improv it's like oh my
God
an interdimensional broadcast of Janet
van dyne's UCB 101 graduating show
broadcast into space and they were like
we hate actors
I like it improv itself like I always
envy people that can do improv because I
could never ever I don't have that like
oh I just get too anxious I'm like yo
don't be it don't be so a koi Tommy
Tommy's The Improv Master over here yeah
I would be terrible don't worry it only
cost me 30 grand uh to get this
worth it
every penny all right but let's vote on
this really weird Theory like what do
you guys think the possibility is that
Janet Van Dyne made a zombie virus for
Kang the king will end up using um as
part of his plan to take over the
Multiverse do you guys think it's Rogue
yes bogus or August I'm taking away
Tommy yeah I love you mg I want to
preface that yes uh but this Theory to
me is the focus
okay
I I love the idea I wish it were true I
think it was a great what if I think it
is a great Marvel zombie storyline I
don't think we're gonna see it in
quantumania that's true
this is a really Rogue out there
that'd be so [__] random it's like all
right guys then zombies like we're just
gonna do zombies now with the quota
Mania why not I know I'm gonna give it
an August because I want it to happen
but I think it's about as likely as
Janet Van Dyne having an improv
101.
imagine both of those things happen
that'd be hilarious
screaming
oh my God like Kevin feige is really
watching our videos my God
what do you think Tom I uh agree with
Tommy and Whitney but I'm giving this a
rogus because it's Rogue Theory and you
know it's funny yeah it's fun to
speculate about what happens you know I
think that it would be more fun to save
the live-action zombies until let's say
Kang Dynasty and let's say Kang opens a
portal we have a live action version of
those zombies falling because not
everybody saw what if so I would be fine
if they did that again that being said I
think it would tie in really nicely be
really cool maybe it could still be what
the movie's about but we maybe only see
a few zombies just give us a little
taste because there's no way we're not
getting live action Marvel zombies
There's no way oh yeah it's too good of
a too good of an idea and whether it's
now or whether it's they're saving it
for you know the new portal scene and
you know in Kang Dynasty with all these
zombies coming out I'll take it but I
think it's a really cool idea to give
like what was Janet doing down there and
I think that's more interesting because
it ties into everything we've seen and
it's not something just new and randomly
like an improv troop or whatever else
like it was something with Stakes of
what she was doing and why she's so
scared as opposed to just like I helped
King build a time bomb I'd be like all
right I guess like that that's probably
what's gonna what it's gonna do but how
cool would it be if it were mom for
zombies so rogus it would be cool it'd
be super super and I also do feel like
Marvel Zombies is the plan for Marvel
Studios and I feel like the seeds was
planted like a while ago like because
remember yeah
um continue
the beginning of Civil War when the
Avengers stopped that infection from the
the red vial from releasing like oh yeah
maybe that could have been the seeds I
mean the beans for um a zombie Marvel
Zombies event I don't know
yeah I love that but or it could just be
covid-19 who knows but up next Thomas
next
what up next Tommy has an amazing Rogue
theory about some of those creatures in
the quantum realm but first be sure to
check out the rockstarsmerch.com where
you can grab one or even two of our many
awesome new shirts inspired by the
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania and
there's still time to order now and have
it delivered in time to wear on opening
weekend of quantumania I even helped
with one of the designs featuring Kang
the man conquering himself if you can
support the channel and check out all of
our awesome merch options over at
newrockservicemerch.com also nerd
riot.shop and that's our new URL because
the Rockstar's merch is now nerd Riot
but we also want to thank nordvpn for
sponsoring this podcast and guys have
you ever gotten extremely hyped to watch
a new series or film only to discover
it's not available for streaming in your
country well nordvpn has got you guys
covered with nordvpn you can switch your
virtual location on your device with
just one click giving you the ability to
access streaming services from over 60
countries at no extra cost this opens up
a Quantum rail full of entertaining
content which you wouldn't be able to
access without nordvpn with over 5400
servers in 60 countries nor VPN gives
you access to games and streaming
platforms that are currently not
available in your region and the best
part is nordvpn will not slow down your
online experience they've done the speed
tests and nordvpn is the fastest VPN out
there in the world and they will keep
you safe from hackers malicious sites
and pop-ups while browsing the internet
with just one click imagine having so
much power with just one click it hasn't
been seen before in the history of man
if you're a rogue Theory fan you can
help support the show and grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal at going to
nordvpn.com Rogue Theory and you will
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus a bonus gift it's completely
risk-free with rewards 30 day money back
guarantee that's nordvpn.com Rogue
Theory and when you take norvpn so much
for sponsoring this podcast you guys are
the best we also want to thank Dane for
sponsoring this podcast as well we've
all had moments in our life where an
unexpected expense came along that
completely abandons your monthly budgets
maybe a medical emergency or a fender
bender something you weren't expecting
just annihilate your bank account
luckily Dave can help you out in a pinch
if you really need it Dave is at the
banking app that could help you get up
to 500 instantly with extra cash with
Dave there's no interest late fees or
credit check that's more money to fill
your tank finally get your car repaired
or catch up on bills without having to
wait for your next paycheck you can
finally tackle those expenses that have
been stressing you out millions of
people have already downloaded the Dave
app to get the financial relief that
they need with extra cash so if you're
in a pinch and need some extra help
download Dave and think of it as a
helping hand from future you download
the Dave app from the app store right
now or go to dave.com Rogue again that
is dave.com Rogue sign up for an extra
cash account and get up to 500 instantly
for terms and conditions go to dave.com
Legal instant transfer fees apply
banking services provided by evolve Bank
and Trust member FDIC but yes now it is
time for our second topic that will be
presented by the wonderful the amazing
the Rogue a king Tommy bech told take it
away Tommy good evening
our first story good evening
here here is my
um here's my rogue Theory today guys and
again I won't be holding a vote at the
end because it's it's rogus
not a democracy
it's another Ant-Man topic we remember
in Ant-Man 2 Ant-Man of the WASP uh
Janet was able to use Scott like a radio
to communicate from inside the quantum
realm outside uh we remember in the
trailers for Ant-Man Quantum Mania
Cassie describes the device she built as
a two-way radio into the quantum realm
so here's my theory in the movie Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania when they first
all go down Cassie is not going to be
equipped to be in the quantum realm
Scott is going to sacrifice himself
momentarily by giving her his equipment
that allows the pin particles and
Quantum realm not to mess with your
brain causing him to have a bit of a
brain damage moment a bit of a like lack
of oxygen before he's ultimately I'm
saved now Brandon Barrick and I have
been discussing on the break room that
we believe people were going in and out
of the quantum realm in this movie it's
not all going to take place in the
quantum realm uh so I think well Scott
is kind of a little mentally foggy
characters from the outside world that
he knows are going to manifest in those
animated motion capture characters that
we see in
um uh in the trailer we know in the
casting for instance David Dalmatian
he's playing a character it's not quas
quas is uh is uh uh William Jackson
Harper's character
uh David I'm actually is playing an
animated like kind of bubble character I
think the reason that has David
dumbassion's voice is because it's going
to be Scott putting voices that he knows
from outside to the animated characters
so I think we're gonna get voice cameos
all of The Wizard of Oz like people from
The Real World are now showing up in
quantumania but in exaggerated form so I
think we're gonna get a Michael Pena
voice Cameo even though it hasn't been
announced in the form of someone in the
quantum realm trying to explain
something to Scott it's going to have
luis's voice all of a sudden I think
there could be some sort of quantumania
law enforcement that has Bobby
cannaval's voice kind of an iconic deep
voice you know the thing is that people
have to have voices I think the
bartender in the scene is going to have
the guy from the coffee shop that goes
thank you Spiderman I think his voice
will be represented
but I think it goes deeper than that I
think we could also have some Avengers
cameos maybe Samuel no sin shows up
maybe you know his voice saying maybe
Scott is assigning Sam Wilson's voice
something Bruce Banner's voice to a
large hulking Quantum Mania thing
possibly even a dead Avenger what if we
get a Natalie you know someone in the
quantum realm has uh has Natalie's voice
so I think as part of Scott's brain
healing from giving Cassie his suit uh
so that she's not affected by the by the
quantumania and Pym particles
he's gonna hear voices that are familiar
to him in that even though the people
are in the real world may not be
communicating directly via two-way radio
his brain will become a two-way radio
pulling their voices from the outside
world into the quantum realm to help him
figure out what's going on
I rest my case
dude you're really smart wow that was
like a really cool smart Theory I didn't
do it I'm into it it's it's like I like
that it's like very smart but also
extremely creative like it's a type of
thing that like I can see like Marvel
Studios like actually doing because no
one would actually think of think about
it and so like their experience for the
person I'd be like oh my God what is
this amazing thing that's happening so
and he just freaking trivia
[Laughter]
that's our show guys thank you so much
kids this is how you do it
um but no I I really have been wanting
um Ant-Man free to address this like
that weird it like I put it uh antenna
in your head Scott type of science that
they introduced in Ant-Man 2 and I feel
like like having that be really fun way
to sort of like retroactively add
Michael Pena and like all the the x-con
um friends into the movie when they you
know even if they weren't originally
planned to be in the movie have a nice
little animated so you can be like hey
this is what's happening in the quantum
realm I'm a weird bug man now Scott but
I'm not actually here I'm in your brain
that's just really fun I just I love
stupid like not stupid but like really
like yeah I mean it's a little stupid
it's okay
did y'all ever see that movie The Nice
Guys the Shameless America
the other guys the other guys sorry
fantastic and uh yeah yeah this is yeah
Ryan Gosling and wrestle Crow and
there's a scene where I think it's Ryan
Gosling is like passing out because he's
wasted and uh Hannibal buress's voice
comes to him in like the form of a b
like a little bumblebee temporarily and
it's so funny and like and smart and
cool and terrifying and I'm so hilarious
I really like this idea Tommy it's very
cool you were right we probably are all
gonna give it a rogus we probably don't
have to vote this is amazing it's true
well feel free to vote now if you'd like
I mean I know that Tommy put an antenna
in my head to vote rocus and that's why
there's a two-way radio it's a two-way
radio in my head no no I love Tom and I
hate to run in this parade but double
rogus though I also like I do yeah
oh suspense you know I think that the
other thing that's really cool that you
didn't I remember that I don't know if
this was incorporating your theory but
it made me think of immediately is the
whole reason why he that Hank needed
Scott is because the suit takes a toll
and he can't run and we didn't say they
didn't say what happened they didn't say
like what what that toll is and maybe if
it's not you know
um maybe if it's not like him losing his
helmet and you know having brain fog
maybe this could be part of the toll
they're talking about it in the quantum
we're out in the quantum realm tolls
work differently maybe and this is and
this is what how it's it's it's you know
taking a toll on his body because
nothing has been done to fix whatever
that problem is right he's like here's
the suit here's the pin particles but
there's no they've never addressed that
again as far as by the way Scott you're
never gonna have the problem you know
Hank had like you know they've never
said that so you know he could he could
get to a point where he can't use the
suit anymore either is what I was gonna
say so that's a it's a really cool idea
well thank you yeah yeah I I think yeah
and just so for viewers it's addressed
in the comics as the Lang family line
has a inherent ability to absorb pin
particles because once you have enough
particles around you your body starts to
create them and the way they explain it
in the comics is Scott and Cassie
naturally have a uh kind of a stronger
tolerance for the effects of pin
particles and they create them as their
own defensive pin particles uh at a more
rapid rate than the average human but I
don't know if they're ever going to get
into that in these things uh so yeah all
right great for roguses for me guys we
here we saw that coming up
but no this is all great I love all this
but now it is time for our Rogue
question are you guys ready for this yes
let's do it
that's how we're gonna get copyright
strike all right here we go uh we got
our first look at the new deuce the
deuce Deuces that's not a thing that's
not a word um that's that's a different
thing
um two girls one cup Universe coming to
you okay
um here we go
oh my God I'm so sorry
all right but we got our first look at
the new DCU slate this week thanks to an
announcement from wonderful man and
friend James Gunn and we're excited for
a lot of the new films and series that
have been announced but I want to hear
your rogus pitches or what you would
like to see in the new DCU
two words five syllables
Mr
mixolplexoplex and make him a cutie
little stinker that just comes in here
give me an interdimensional beating you
can only be sent home by saying his name
backwards oh my God
that would be amazing
yes that would be so hilarious
10 out of 10 casters uh what do you guys
think oh uh I'm gonna just use the thing
that uh we were talking about the other
day Mt which is I need them to make new
dances at the beginning of every season
of Peacemaker and I also need that show
to go on forever because my favorite
thing about last year I'm not kidding
dude empty she and I would wake up at
like so early in the morning to watch
Peacemaker before we had to go to work
and we would text each other and we
would just doodling
friendship across the country while
boogieing and that's all I want that's
all I want from the DCU is more it
really is the best way to wake up in the
morning you get your muscles stretched
and you get ready to watch one of the
best TV shows of all time
but like instead of the Marvel like
intro with all the comic Pages it's the
DC level coming up and it's like
[Music]
a song
Yeah The Death of Superman
it's like the freaking job the Justice
League freaking laser accidentally fires
on the planet and like decimates the
city it's like oh my God people are dead
[Laughter]
I love that
um I think there are kind of on their
way to doing this but I would
I was um is the is the animated DC stuff
like uh Justice League uh man that show
the animation you know rip no longer on
HBO or my God like so good so good I
just put that background sometimes but
anyway they towards the end of that they
did some really interesting fun episodes
and where they gave characters you know
a whole a highlight that you would and
you would never even think of them in
that way and there was this one episode
where
um I already forget the details uh but
Solomon Grundy Dr Fate and like hot girl
went to this other dimension because
um they needed to they needed the like
the dead man or something to do
something and that's why they brought
Grundy and uh Mark Hamill famously
voiced Grundy on all the Justice League
stuff and I was like how cool if they
made a live-action version of that
episode where you could get Mark Hamill
to come do the voice and then you know
because Granny's always been this like
Punchy character that just like nobody
really cares about and they they gave
him such a heart and an arc in that that
you didn't even expect totally redeemed
him and like and there's a whole bunch
of other episodes like um you know the
one um
for the man who has everything where
Superman was under the influence of the
sorrow uh oh my God like literally
you're naming two of my favorite
episodes
the card game I forgot their name but
when the Batman
real flash gang thank you where uh or um
you know they had to Batman had to go
talk you know ace off of destroying the
world it was so sad because she was
about to die because she was about to
have a brain aneurysm yes
moments like that that I I hope they
they do or and then they kind of already
are I think but I would love to see them
um you know adapt some of those because
the animated show took from the comics
and took some new stuff so I'd love to
see some of the some of the Justice
League some of those things from the
animated come over to live action and we
get to see some of those I'm sure James
is honestly yes too oh yeah like I think
James Dunn said that he's going to draw
a lot from the Justice League animated
series
um for his plan so like I can 100 see
this and like Solomon run to you I 100
agree it's such a tragic character and
like I would I would love to see James
gun tackle a really sad but like really
adult and real take on you know Solomon
Grundy and like have him be this
redeemed like Hulk type figure because I
honestly feel like Solomon Grundy should
be the Hulk of the Justice League just
be like hey I used to be evil but now
I'm good and I'm big enough
you know yeah right it's just so I love
little big Derpy characters
exactly uh I like that type of dynamic
and like Solomon Grundy I want to see a
Solomon Grundy show so bad yeah
that'd be freaking awesome it would be
rad it would be something different and
like Everyone likes to go to anti-hero
so Solomon Grundy all day every day I'm
just kidding only on a Monday
but that's it for this episode of Rogue
Theory thanks to Our Guest Whitney van
lening him Tommy bechtold and Tom
Michaelson support our Channel by
checking out of our awesome merch over
at nerdriot.shop you can follow me at
mastertainment follow me rockstars and
all sorts of platforms and be sure to
subscribe to our channel here on YouTube
see you next time we love you guys so
much be safe and goodbye
see ya